welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host definition
and we're just going to be talking about
some batman pictures that just got
leaked
uh we won't be posting this just because
we don't want to spoil anything for
people who
haven't had a chance to check out the
trailer so we're recording this in the
past and just giving our thoughts on the
initial look at bruce wayne
now as you can see he's very very very
emo
i you know what at first i was like what
this is actually from batman and then
the more i looked at it i thought you
know what
i'm digging what they're doing so
basically what they've done is they've
taken the entire
i've been saying for so long now that
this entire film it's got
one design focus in mind so the car is
very
um stylized in a certain way which
complements the suit
the suit complements the bat bike it's i
think as we see the trailer at night um
you've probably already seen it watching
this you're gonna see that a lot of
things line up it's gonna be a very diy
grounded feel to the movie i'm guessing
and
very gothic as well we can clearly see
that here
um and yeah so basically the way this
looks to me
is that bruce wayne is completely
depressed
he's a he's a multi-billionaire and but
he just looks so
dour and you really get the intensity
intensity
that i can't even look them in the eye
because you're scaring me
the intensity that robert pattinson is
trying to deliver here
this is looks like it's at a funeral um
now there are leaks that there's a big
funeral scene in the movie by the way
spoilers
so there are leaks that there's a big
funeral see in the movie if it's in the
trailer already
then congratulations you already know
and you can dislike the video
uh but yeah there's meant to be a big
scene at a funeral which is held for
the mayor and at that stuff kind of goes
down now it looks like bruce is kind of
clocked this year and
he's getting ready for a fight now the
next
picture how did that get in here
now here we can see bruce sort of
working away in the bat cave
i love the way that he's just basically
got a mechanics bench and the batmobile
um i don't know if you know but there
was a batman yeah one film that was in
production with darren aronofsky
and frank miller that was basically
meant to have bruce
as a mechanic um with another mechanic
called big al who was alfred
and he just sort of worked away and we
can see that being brought across here
which i'm really
really enjoying the bat cave looks
brilliant very very grounded
feel once more we did actually have
leaks that are reported on
and that said the batcave was like
basically a mechanic shop
and it's good to see that this has been
brought across here there's very few
computers
very few technology um things and just
looks like the focus is on the car and
batman himself
and the last photo i'm guessing is bruce
looking over that mechanics bench
and he has got the black stuff around
his eyes now what this
most likely means is that the bat suit
that we've seen for the very least won't
have the white eyes
there'd be no need to have mascara on if
he did have white eyes
so i'm guessing that this is pretty much
making it clear that
he does he's doing what he always does
now what they have done here
that they've never done in any other
batman film is actually
show the actor with the black under his
eyes you might remember in batman
returns michael keaton ripped off the
mask
black wasn't there all of a sudden
didn't show up for ben affleck and
didn't show up for christian bale it's
always been something that i've
personally wanted to see because
it just adds so much more to the
character i think
being able to see him like this it looks
very vulnerable but also very stern
and it is such an intimidating figure
now this is a really
really good thing at the time of
recording this i'm of course
very hyped to see how it delivers i'll
have seen the trailer by the time this
video goes out
but hey looking forward to it me in the
past looking forward to dc final being
done because i tell you today hasn't
been a fun one for me with all the
technical issues
anyway thanks for watching this video
we've got a whole host of dc fandom
content to watch
so make sure you check it out after this
i've been definition you know you've
been the best and i'll see you next time
take care peace
much love
you